et bien je te dire contrairement à ce
que tu penses c'est pas un truc physique
ah ouais c'est quoi non c'est la bêtise
ou l'ennui ah bon on sera jamais
ensemble l'ennui non tu es hyper drôle
et tu es intelligent bah ça se voit que
tu me connais pas c'est le cancer du
couple et tu sais moi je suis pasteur
weekend avec un mec qui était hyper beau
tu vois c'est ah ouais tu parles le
weekend déjà dans la voiture
ouais quand il parle ça t'emmerde tu
vois et là j'étais en train de compter
combien il y a 2 minutes
fois 1h30 waouh tu vois et effectivement
tu vas tu vas pas touché son pommeau de
vitesse pendant le
deuxième le plus beau du monde avec tout
le reste du weekend tu t'ennuies c'est
pareil pour une meuf la bêtises
de l'ennui
alors évidemment l'ennui mais attention
que tous les moches intelligents
m'écrivent pas non plus il faut il faut
il faut
oh toi ambitieux drôle et beau ça existe
moi ce qui m'amuse c'est que j'ai un
certain âge maintenant mais tu es
j'allais dire mon premier échec on n'est
pas encore sorti du ring et tu veux moi
c'est mon premier
manque d'hygiène manque d'humour
[Rires]
c'est pas une question
non mais c'est même pas une question de
faire des des gros cadeaux des choses
comme ça c'est des petites attentions
c'est un truc voilà j'ai pensé voilà
c'est c'est un petit mot c'est un c'est
une attention j'ai pensé à toi c'est un
truc peu importe mais voilà et il manque
d'hygiène c'est rédhibitoire les ongles
sales ou voilà le truc un peu douteux ça
c'est pas possible les jours que ça sent
le match pro
parmesan
et donc d'humour quelqu'un qui comprend
pas l'humour qui est pas drôle
franchement c'est pas possible voilà tu
as éliminé énormément de monde
Superman n'existe pas ma fille je
demande de qualité de cœur et
intelligence pas grand chose
alors moi l'hygiène j'ai eu des
mauvaises expériences
quand même c'est important de bien se
laver mes demoiselles parce que parfois
c'est important de l'installer tout le
monde
parce que vous pensez je suis
extrêmement propre extrêmement lavé que
tu as perdu tes yeux
on les voit de moins en moins
je dis la vérité moi je trouve j'ai
trouvé un peu fatigué
il avait la gueule en billet
il boitait
pour devenir mannequin
non pas pour les gars
de mon physique avantageux et qui
s'améliore de jour en jour pour une
marque de fringues
elle veut faire faillite dans combien de
temps
parce qu'on va être là-bas avec la mine
la ministre des PME on peut déjà lui en
parler parce qu'il y a une faillite qui
arrive bientôt là donc je pourrais être
égérie d'une grande marque et Tom et
Jerry
cheveux aussi parce qu'il avait très
beau cheveux
plus faire de égérie
et donc l'hygiène c'est très important
mais le talent et la beauté sont enfin
récompensés signe déjà là t'inquiète pas
mais c'est quoi costume pourquoi je ne
peux pas en parler les mecs je suis sûr
que c'est lui qui a contacté quelqu'un
c'est pas faux
[Applaudissements]
connais tellement il doit avoir un pote
qui a lancé une marque maintenant tu
sais que tu cherches pas des modèles
mais c'est exactement comme ça que c'est
passé
exactement et je lui ai fait de la peine
et ben il était généreux non c'est
pareil non mais c'est bon on verra ça et
donc pour répondre à votre question
c'est terrible et c'est et c'est de plus
en plus hein
[Musique]
le pire du pire c'est la bêtise les gens
qui n'ont rien à dire et qui parle de
choses qui sont totalement superflus et
notamment les filles qui mettent des qui
mettent des rajouts des fois ils mettent
des rajouts c'est ça ton problème
mais sans déconner comment on peut être
aussi nul mais ça ça y est les gars mais
réveillez-vous les choses j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] il a 50 ans il a aucun rythme
frère il veut décoller
[Applaudissements]
c'est ouf
c'est naturel
[Applaudissements]
quelques mots clés que tu vas voir tu
vas pouvoir parler Delphine on les
rajoute
alors moi le temps de réfléchir là on a
mis une demi-heure
c'est pas
ça me dégoûte
non parce que j'adore faire la fête non
mais ça je peux le comprendre et donc et
donc
c'est pas chanter moi je me rappelle moi
j'ai refusé à l'époque j'étais en colo
j'étais colo il y avait une meuf elle
était hyper mignonne elle voulait me
pécho et ben dans c'est hyper mal j'ai
basé et c'est un copain à moi qui l'a
pécho j'ai beaucoup Grecs
après oui donc voilà donc quand la
personne n'a pas le rythme et tout ça
mais quand tu rentres
hier soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle va prendre un verre avec un mec
pour la première fois
j'ai perdu mon micro parce que quelque
part
oh bordel de merde bon alors j'ai pas
fini j'avais pas fini
le rythme en danse ça peut être ça peut
être comparé au rythme à un autre rythme
et du coup ça donne au rythme de l'amour
c'est quand ton shopping
alors
les gens qui se plaignent tout le temps
les gens génial quand ils ont pessimiste
de la vie etc je suis un peu comme ça il
faut exactement le contraire sinon ça va
pas il faut quelqu'un
Cyril tout de suite ça se voit dans les
yeux ça se voit ça se sent bien sûr mais
tu as vraiment des exigences toi
oui aussi mais j'ai un odorat ultra
développé genre bionique et les odeurs
il y a un mec qui a pété sur Rouen là
donc les odeurs de pied ou autre voilà
je les sens de très très loin donc c'est
même un problème j'ai un odorat
extrêmement sensible et comment tu fais
à côté de ville
ils sont très bon état
alors oui alors moi l'hygiène comme tout
le monde de l'esprit il faut pas qu'elle
soit feignante j'aime pas les gens qui
sont fainéants je déteste les gens qui
dort toute la journée
[Applaudissements]
merci frérot d'être là bravo pour le
Ballon d'Or
[Musique]
c'est comme ça que tu es où sur ma vie
bah je vais te dire il y a des mecs ça
lui rirait pas d'être beau gosse
[Rires]
il est beau comme ça c'est comme ça
qu'on l'aime tu le verrais Moktar hyper
tu vois ce qui est vrai
Mokhtar et c'est comme ça qui me plaît
mais comme ça quoi
exactement
je le trouve magnifique l'émission
alors les ongles rongés les pellicules
sur la veste ah oui alors ça j'avais
oublié quelqu'un qui se met le doigt
dans le nez
quelqu'un qui ronge ses ongles de pieds
là
mais c'est vrai c'est quoi tu as déjà vu
un gars
il est commun
allez mets une série là sur Netflix
on en parlait tout à l'heure avec
Delphine au maquillage vous allez au
restaurant avec quelqu'un il vous dit
pas tu m'invites ou je t'invite mais on
partage
ça c'est d'accord avec ça
tu veux t'émanciper
il s'est passé un truc énorme quoi
Raymond m'a invité au resto non c'est la
première fois de sa vie mais non
il m'a invité au resto c'est lui qui a
payé ah ouais c'est pas la première fois
bah c'est la quatrième fois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est du chêne mon frère
chez toi donc de présenter les chèques
en trois fois
dans un restaurant dans le sud là il y
avait des grillades là c'est chez moi
il part pour les payer
et je veux venir en speed il était blanc
sur la tête
pas trop du restaurant
il a bu trois verres
il a fait semblant que il avait oublié
de me dire qu'il m'avait invité et
finalement j'ai dû l'inviter
la note était la note c'est un truc
c'est lui qui a moyen
les frères lui sont déconnectés Obélix
frère
[Rires]
je sortais des biftecks de sa poche
[Applaudissements]
très rapidement
ça vous dérange non
on n'est pas merdé par les bristols hein
[Applaudissements]
il faut rester un peu bien sûr Raymond
il reste tout le temps avec moi
il a surtout pas d'amis
c'est important que je sois là pour lui
bonsoir alors pour moi le plus gros tue
l'amour c'est évidemment le P mais pas
n'importe lequel le P aquatique
j'ai une histoire très passionnelle avec
une fille qui s'appelait Séverine et qui
était un peu pétomane et en fait à
chaque fois
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
n'importe quoi
de lumière chez lui
on dirait qu'il s'habille sans
électricité
on dirait on dirait une trousse de
maquillagement
excuse-moi si tu as d'autres conneries à
dire comme ça
arrête arrête c'est horrible c'est
horrible c'est pour entendre quelqu'un
qui pétait dans la piscine et c'est
devenu un jacuzzi c'est nul
merci voilà merci mais je connais je
connais la fin de l'histoire
non mais c'est vrai tu vois ta meuf
passait dans le salon comme ça devant la
télé
[Musique]
tu crois qu'un mec qui passe en faisant
mieux c'est pareil
deux semaines avec toi
c'est du métal les gens croyais que
c'était fait greffer un coussin péteur
n'importe quoi il est 19h
de la femme et je vais vous dire moi
aucune exigence
moi ce que je veux c'est de la sincérité
jamais été aussi ça par contre quelqu'un
qui a une quéquette c'est rédhibitoire
[Applaudissements]
tu sais quoi c'est une vraie question et
si juste rien sauf le je change de sexe
c'est à dire quoi exactement
c'est non toujours non oui donc c'est
pas vrai de sexe alors tu as raison donc
ne fais rien
je crois plus rien tout simplement tu
vas pas te faire chier allez faire une
opération tout ça pour revenir ici la
gueule en biais et que je dise non c'est
pas bon vu ton compte en banque je
pourrais le faire
attention
c'est de ça c'est de ça